let's talk about all the support in this
room for you Courtney and Travis were
out here to support you what does it
feel like to have people constantly
showing up for you like now they expect
you to do great so that's like a bit of
pressure no
um I think it's so nice to have my
friends and family here to support me I
mean
I've it definitely means a lot I try not
to look at them while I'm performing
because you know makes me nervous but
it's always it always feels good to see
them after and just get to talk to them
and have them see me do something that
I'm having a lot of fun doing they never
get to see me dance so this is fun yeah
and there's like these Six Degrees of
connection because Mark you danced with
Kim and I did
but how cool is that all the connections
it feels like it's kind of meant to be
it is a full circle move it was cool to
see Courtney out there and Travis
tonight and um it's just really cool
that they came to support you know
yeah I want to talk about you not liking
eye contact and not knowing how to flirt
which both things I think are adorable
at
her in general
[Music]
does land and support help that in any
way does he make you feel more
comfortable with giving pretty eyes to
somebody or something like that I mean
it's not like I'm good at eye contact
with him either or flirting
no no for the first like few weeks that
we started hanging out we would just sit
there in silence because he's equally as
awkward as I am sounds peaceful it's
great a lot of calmness but I'm working
on the eye contact thing
when you guys are sitting together
silent who breaks the ice first who
breaks the silence first
depends really yeah
wow you guys would be great meditation
Partners we watch a lot of TV so you
don't want to like talk during TV shows
you're tied in the top spot once again
how does that feel what's your message
to the other leaders
I mean it feels great I was definitely
getting very nervous right before he was
too nervous why what made you nervous
this time just going first I was a
little scared for that but our dance
everything that I was nervous about went
smoothly so I was very happy with it
foreign
I love the theatrics in the beginning it
was just such a like a moment where
you're like what is happening I don't
know what's going on it was really great
um I want to talk about the steaminess
of bond how did you feel uh about the
performance in combination with the
costumes the whole thing together I mean
I'm a bond fan I grew up in the UK so
you know it's very much part of my
upbringing sure so you know Daniel Craig
is Frozen where my Bond's growing up
listen they're looking for a new bomb
suit I'm too short I think but I'll be
the villain if they need one listen I
like the white eye but yeah I love the
villain stuff
um it's just great man if you grew up on
it for me it was super nostalgic Charlie
has never seen a Bond movie
Charlie
Charlie tell me that you've seen at
least a bond trailer
I have not I said I was going to watch
one to prepare for this I
I've spent so much time rehearsing
that's right and get to make time to
watch the movie she's blaming you for
this one
[Music]
foreign